qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cette
séance de questions et d'actualité assez
tendue notamment sur la question des
violences lors des manifestations sur la
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre est-ce
que le gouvernement a une forme de
responsabilité dans toutes les violences
qu'on voit c'est un échec de la part de
ministre de l'Intérieur pas le moins du
monde moi je pense que les choses sont
claires d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu dans
plusieurs questions qui ont été posées
sur les violences en réalité enfin qui
imagine dans ce pays que des gendarmes
que des policiers que des militaires
d'ailleurs parfois pour les missions de
service public avec bonheur ce délecte
d'aller massacrer manifestants mais
l'intolus que ça n'existe pas en vrai
quand vous avez recevez des pluies de
projectiles de la part des manifestants
vous avez des réactions quand vous
respectez la loi va pardon de vous dire
il y a peu de chances que les choses se
passent mal la police dans Paris ou dans
les grandes villes a contribué à
maintenir la sécurité de l'ensemble des
manifestants qui manifestaient contre le
projet retraite c'est pas une limite du
droit manifester il faut que les
manifestations quelle qu'elle soit
pacifiques soit sûr et qu'on puisse
sécuriser les manifestants si vous avez
des Black Blocs si vous avez des gens
violents qui viennent pour casser
forcément qu'il prenait un risque et je
regrette infiniment ça a été dit dans
l'hémicycle à plusieurs reprises je
regrette infiniment que des élus avec
écharpe soit allé à des manifestations
interdites interdites par le préfet en
l'occurrence m'interdit aussi après
conférence de presse du procureur de la
République c'est-à-dire c'est pas
seulement l'autorité politique c'est
aussi l'autorité judiciaire qui dit
attention danger cette manifestation est
interdite si les gens y vont qu'est-ce
que vous voulez faire ils prennent le
responsabilité mais pour autant les
gendarmes qui étaient à Sainte Soline
étaient là pour protéger et bien c'est
parce qu'il s'est passé parce que
malheureusement vous aviez des centaines
de gens qui sont venus pour fracasser
mais ce que disent les parlementaires
présents lors de ces manifestations
c'est qui il jouait aussi leur rôle de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
de l'action du contrôle du Gouvernement
au Parlement c'est de contrôler l'action
du gouvernement c'est pas de participer
à des manifestations interdites quand
une manifestation est interdite elle est
interdite pour tout le monde du simple
citoyen au parlementaire alors la crise
politique actuelle a aussi été évoqué
dans cette séance de questions
d'actualité la première ministre
Isabelle borne a répondu au président du
groupe socialiste Patrick Kanner en
disant qu'elle allait relancer la
construction d'une nouvelle majorité de
plusieurs majorité de projets durant ce
quinquennat avec un nouveau programme de
gouvernement est-ce que vous pensez que
le gouvernement dessine une sortie de
crise
côté moi j'entends le gouvernement
d'ailleurs et le président de la
République parler de majorité sur des
textes sur des projets depuis le mois de
juin dernier c'est à dire depuis que le
Président de la République n'a plus la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale on nous
dit constamment qu'on va faire une
majorité sur des projets pour le moment
je ne vois rien si ce qui se passe c'est
que on met sur la table un texte et on
dit qu'il prend qu'il soutient c'est pas
comme ça si vous voulez faire avancer
les choses il faut dire aux formations
politiques sur quoi voulez-vous
travailler quels sont les textes que
vous souhaitez dans quelles conditions
dans quel cadre et si un accord sur des
textes là on peut avancer mais c'est pas
moi gouvernement tout seul je fais ce
que je veux et je vous demande de bien
vouloir le voter si vous êtes d'accord
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe merci
beaucoup merci pour votre réaction micro
public c'est non
[Musique]